now Russia's defense minister has
appeared on the Ukrainian front line for
the first time since a mutiny and
demands for his removal the leader of
the Wagner group whose mercenaries have
fought side by side with the Russian
military led a rebellion on Saturday
Nevada's Chief blames Sergey shoigu for
the Fighter's deaths he's also accused
him of incompetence and Corruption after
taking control of Russia's Southern
Command Post in roster vondon evgeny
pregosian demanded sure you'd be handed
over to him to quote restore Justice
well prajogin hasn't been seen in public
since crowds cheered him off from roster
fondant on Saturday evening the Kremlin
said pregosian had agreed to go into
Exile in Belarus the fighters who joined
the march on Moscow would not be
prosecuted for treason
joins us now from Moscow a lot of moving
parts to this story so let's just focus
in on the defense minister and his
appearance finally
yeah exactly the ministry of Defense has
has indeed released a video showing
Minister Sergey shoigu allegedly
visiting and checking the forward
command post of the western group of
Russian forces the group is deployed
into the lugansk front and this is
shogun's indeed first public appearance
since Evgeni pregosian's Rebellion
according to Russian state agencies
says the situation listened to the
reports or the commander of the group
then held a meeting with other
commanders and assigned them their
combat missions he also praised the
Western Group for their successes and
advances and so on just some official
very dry official information there on
the wires some sources allege that the
video may be old but it is probably a
hint that shoigu remains in his post
during the military Rebellion conducted
by head of the Wagner mercenary group
evgeny preggers on Saturday a minister
and ever appeared publicly we saw his
deputies generals surabhiken alexev
yunus Becky of kurov addressing other
Fighters speaking to preggersian in
rostov ondon trying to settle the
conflicts but many were asking back then
about shigu and about his moves and
actually we saw nothing well as we know
as and as you mentioned one of the
progressions accusations were the lack
of Munitions and attacks conducted by
the ministry of Defense on the Wagner
group of course the weekend saw great
upheaval uh in that small area of Russia
and certainly worries in the Kremlin
apparent conversations being held
between the foreign ministries of the
U.S and Russia what more do we know
about that during the Rebellion
exactly we know that the U.S ambassador
to Russia here in Moscow conducted the
context as rather uh the um uh the
Russian foreign Ministry uh because of
the situation with the Wagner group and
they discussed security after the Mutiny
conducted by evgeny preggers
there were no contacts between Minister
lavrov and and Secretary of State
blinken according to reports but
probably well something will be
organized as we understand because of
the situation with the Wagner group
NATO contacted the Russian defense
Ministry that's according to the Italian
La Republica the alliance really feared
a nuclear incident and therefore
according to the Italian press they held
informal contact with with the Russian
side but basically I I think this
information is pretty it's pretty scarce
so and probably we have to to monitor
you know and how the the situation is
developing indeed it certainly still is
a developing situation for the moment
for us in Moscow thank you